The idea of systemic racism is not that people
are operating with a racist mindset or racist
intention.
It's that there's a system that was originally
designed to produce racist outcomes, and it
is continuing to produce them, regardless
of intent within that system.
Through policing, through prosecution, through
incarceration, the criminal justice system
has produced massive declines in crime since
the 1990s.
And those declines have primarily benefitted
black and brown communities across the country.
Is there overwhelming evidence that America’s
criminal justice system is racist?
That was the subject of an online Soho Forum
debate held on Wednesday, June 24th, 2020...
sponsored by Reason.
Arguing that America’s criminal justice
system is, in fact, racist was Radley Balko,
an opinion writer for the Washington Post.
A former Senior Editor at Reason, Balko is
also the author of the books Rise of the Warrior
Cop and The Cadaver King and the Country Dentist.
Defending America’s criminal justice against
the charge of racism was The Manhattan Institute’s
Rafael Mangual, who is a contributing editor
for City Journal.
Here’s Radley Balko vs. Rafael Mangual in
an online debate moderated by Soho Forum
director Gene Epstein.